gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r u garbage it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy or if they're
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in antoni's
basement she is a buzz upstairs so
excited about our guest i have not seen
her this happy she's on the phone she's
telling the girls she's cleaning i
assume it's the guest it could be the
half a bottle of cough medicine that
went missing that could be that i'm not
really sure my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
ru garbage he's a ceo to cfo and the co
and the last man to do that i think was
jack wells from general electric yeah
he's an international businessman give
it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true to roof
cooking then obviously uh i'm
contractually obligated by law to
mention the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.comgarbage
check it the [ __ ] out ladies and
gentlemen love that money and how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good give it up for t-bone
mcscruffin's toby mcbuttons everybody
well we're about to have a good ass time
boys we're about to have fun gang we are
all late we're
we're freaking out that's why we play we
are so excited to have our incredibly
and i mean incredibly special guest here
with us today for the first time he is
one of the funniest one of the most
successful stand-up comedians and
podcaster working today the man
literally needs no introduction he is
the host of the tim dillon show i feel
like i'm on shark tank right now i'm
freaking the [ __ ] out give it up for tim
dillon everybody thank you let's go
thank god this worked out because me and
age fully just would have been going out
for the same roles
the same depressing
like
crooked cop dock worker bloated body in
the river
like just i just read for that what are
you talking about it's sad like thank
god we can do this
because it was when i was not doing this
it would just be five fat guys in a room
yeah in midtown staring at each other
being like there can only be one
and you would just they would literally
you'd go in like i auditioned for the
sopranos movie you'd literally they just
bring you in who'd you read for for that
just some cop okay just some guy i read
for the mayor oh newark yeah yeah yeah i
mean you just walk in after an hour of
sitting there and they go they say and
then you
drop your weapon they're like all right
i remember outside the sand one time we
had just moved to new york and uh you
walked out and you go well there i am
and just pointed it fully
you go that's me all right and then i
left new york i said and then i gave it
to him i said let her fat guy holly will
take it and then the pizza guy rolls can
you blow it in yeah a fat guy has to
relieve you from your job just have to
go like a juice
see me punch in you punch out take off
buddy we can't thank you enough for
coming in oh thank you for having me i
love the hoodie polo look at that this
is a 3xl from dxl yes sir who does not
sponsor me but should and what's great
about when they make clothing for fat
people is they go
why do we make it loud
and let's give them fatigues because
they're not in the military and can't be
but if they feel
everything is the military when you're
at a certain weight everything is an
obstacle course you serve it yeah so
they have this now i don't know if you
noticed but these are polo horses
that's pretty classy oh it's classy it's
real dj khaled
i got another one yeah
buddy what is the origin story of tim
dillon tell me to hold tell me the whole
piece i mean long island kid long island
guy you know
mom's a schizophrenic dad's a failed
musician cocaine at 13.
uh you know
smoke weed
love the ciggies
uh boozed it hard
checks out c average
uh
public school up until holy trinity
catholic school but really a public
school uniform is one of the lower tier
yeah catholic schools you know our
theater arts teachers would make out
with kids and
like that type of school everybody's
having fun playing fast and loose what's
funny about that is that's true
yeah um no brothers or sisters no
brothers or sisters what about cousins
was there a big family
one just died choking on a sandwich
other one's a heroin addict
i mean i swear that's not true i swear
to god what kind of sandwich do you know
we don't know it was a godfather for
sure other one's a heroin addict uh
other one you know they're all it's all
bad i am a gay ex-coq head comedian i'm
the most successful
by far
like it's not even close
um you know dad was going to be a
musician that didn't work what did he
actually do though you sang he wrote
songs and sang
how was he how are you paying the rent
in the mortgage and stuff he was a wine
salesman okay that's probably all right
so he was he
did that
you know he did that and then uh my
mother was a swim teacher
she taught swimming he wasn't really
rolling in the dough
two words legacy money
um
yeah i feel like those lessons took
place in an above ground no she she
collected beanie babies in hess
to even it out the keystone of trash
yeah did you get a headstroke every year
oh yeah sometimes it had a helicopter
yeah yeah those things are all right man
as long as the batteries are good when
you come from the type of human filth i
do
your idea is that you will be saved by
some kind of collectible yes
state quarters are big most people put
their effort or energy
into like some type of functional
business but my mother and many people
like her felt that like if you waited on
a long enough line yeah money was on the
other end of it sure like if you just
stuck it out in a line at burger king to
get the [ __ ] commemorative disney
little mermaid toy set and you've got 10
of them and wrapped them in plastic and
put them under the bed one day your ship
was gonna come in that's your 401k right
there is that stuff still out there is
that still somewhere during hurricane
sandy a lot of it floated down the
street
like you saw like princess diana bears
and stuff just
floating down the street
hurricane sandy finally i think was the
nail
in the coffin
jesus christ but every now and then my
my uncle will go on ebay and sell one or
two beanie babies so we could give my
mother money at the mental institution
is it too dark i'm sorry we've just
started
hey you're getting the golden even call
this are you garbage
should we even put a question mark was
mcdonald's monopoly a big deal
mcdonald's monopoly was huge my friend's
parents collected marlboro miles
hey i mean i did my family yeah like
they had coats they had a tent yeah
yeah they had an entire outdoors yeah a
canteen
marlborough canteen
my friend shane mcgoulin
italian kid
so just to give you an idea it's uh yeah
yikes what was the house was a single
family home single family home two
stories not a bad house we had an
in-ground pool that's good because my
mother taught swimming in it okay which
is uh which was nice she did it at the
house she did it at the house that's the
equivalent of cutting hair in the garage
every now and then she she would also do
it in the the rack she'd do it a
direction
but she was like you know you get the
private money sure in the house the
money's in the in calls yeah doing side
work hey listen we can do it at the rec
center or we can lower a little bit i
pocket most of the cash
we just shocked the pool come on so
that's where uh that's where they were
at not big savers of money where does
where where did they come from but they
how back is the irish
forever so my grandfather came over to
this country when he was four on a boat
okay uh he was really successful he
ended up being like a millionaire
multi-millionaire general contractor
worked his way up dad's dad
yeah dad's dad okay and my father
inherited absolutely none of the
ambition drive intelligence grit
determination or longing for his family
to have a better life my dad got none of
that
he uh
he did like a couple of cocktails but he
didn't inherit anything else my father's
um family
a little bit of money but again it was
the old generation where you didn't get
any of it right so you didn't get any
but a lot of it went to the church my
mother's father damn died of a heart
attack because he was big into
amphetamines
they're gonna taken he was a drunk and
he took pills jesus and then my mother
ahead of his time my mother's mother
was a saint my grandmother who i loved
who like helped raise me she raised two
kids no husband because he had you know
od'd
or whatever
and then
or whatever
my dad's family had money my dad
from the eulogy i like it my dad's
family lived in mutton town which is a
really nice part of long island we're
like jennifer anthony uh jennifer lopez
and mark anthony lived okay uh it's like
brookville mutton town they lived in a
really night my grandfather two acre
home pool tennis court all that stuff
that's the crazy thing about long island
is how
mixed in the money and the trash yes
like insane
like gatsby homes yeah [ __ ] some of
the oldest money in in the country and
then we have levittown where people are
falling down on fentanyl oh it's bad
right there in a diner yeah
so it's a real
uh chasm
damn yeah that is [ __ ] so that's the
origin jesus that's that and you went to
college no
nassau community college and then i
dropped out okay i went to nashville
community college i was on the debate
team i enjoyed that you're probably
dunking on people dunking on people real
good real good at that
um
then
i got into selling mortgages right
because my my debate partner had a range
rover and i said [ __ ] yeah what do how
do you do this he goes you sell
mortgages i'm like great
so i started that
and then uh cocaine came back into the
picture in a nice way
stopped by for the weekend yeah and then
some pills a little perk-a-doodle-doo
that was probably in their heyday when
pills started really cooking they were
like no one knew anything at that my
morning routine was a big egg and cheese
two eggs over medium salt pepper ketchup
bacon obviously cheese ah american
cheese on a roll kaiser roll kaiser roll
untoasted gotta be soft unless i will
complain
[Applause]
a double tall non-fat lattes and being
responsible okay
uh
and two perk-a-doodle-dinks
perk-a-doodle-doos perkys and uh about
eight
uh newport cigarettes on the way to work
that's a good morning
that's a-okay it's a good breakfast
morning that makes am radio helps you
[ __ ] you get to the office you take a
[ __ ] for about 30 minutes
you sit down at your desk for about two
minutes everything settles you take a 20
25 minute [ __ ]
and then you come back and start the day
that's all right dude and there's a lot
of people doing that right now shout out
to them
shout out to the people oh man
25 minute percocet [ __ ] at work a couple
of perks and a cup of coffee in the
morning too
it was newborns i started you know and
now i'm like back i go on and off the
cigs what do you smoke now marlborough
lights every now and then you gotta
gentlemen
i started with marlborough reds that me
and my friend shea would steal out of
his mother
yeah we started with rats then
check this
for no reason at all we went to basic
unfiltered jesus christ this guy's a at
13 years old
basic unfiltered just because we're like
[ __ ] it why not
because his grandmother had basic unfil
so then we just like a bargain we used
to have to stand outside of like a of
course like a
lazy cow whatever
and uh we'd have to go hey can you buy
us a pack of cigarettes and people would
which was nice of course that's how you
got sick then people would go hey man he
gave me a pack of cigarettes back then
now
nobody would ever do it
back then people
so we we're basic unfiltered then we
said all right this is [ __ ] old and
stupid we went to marlboro menthol
lights
and we we chilled with those for a while
it's like a candy cane and then the
newport stayed around for the vast
majority of um
and then i switched off the new ports
because they were tough i went back to
marlborough reds and then eventually the
marlboro lights there you go
we did we did noops too yeah yeah for
some reason you're like 14 you because
they're around they're really they're
around the people they have good
marketing back in the day too they made
those beach parties look all right they
tell you that it increases your high 15
percent it does have a newport i'll tell
you because of the fiberglass it takes
you to the next that's right
it cuts it it cuts your lawn if you
smoke weed if you're watching this
you're a kid
it's a family show tim smoke a newport
afterwards because it just puts you in
that right frame sure of course of
course exactly
when you when people would buy you sigs
you would stand out there and wait and
you would like you could always tell by
the car
like whatever car pulled up you're like
this guy's a father was there a main guy
that you that you knew no it we would
just stand outside
and it's horribly embarrassing when they
say no we're 14 years old
and they're like no i can't do that
you could always tell we would if the
guy if a guy got out and left his car
running you're like that guy will buy
some good stuff
smoking was a good size oh yes
give them five bucks a pack was probably
like 275 or three bucks yeah
you can keep the change we'll give you
five you have to change i'd almost get
you a pack there's something in it for
you you wet your beak we used to go hey
go in there
get get me two vanilla dutches
and two packs of newports
and uh
you know thank you so much
and then if they said yes we'd be like
[ __ ] yeah
and then i remember one time this was
great
this was literally this is where we go
like this we go
hey because they also had sandwiches
grab a sandwich
couple of sun chips for the gang too so
eventually uh you know he just got us to
six but yeah and then eventually he got
me a sandwich and then eventually we got
the guy in town who didn't care of
course the uh the the the the guy who
just sold you the six oh yeah you find
that guy for sure find the guy so on a
day-to-day basis your mom and your mom
and dad were taking care and stuff like
that you said your grandmother kind of
raised you well my mother and father
were doing what boomers did which is
like they put you on a school bus
sure they drop you off at a thing they
go good luck we wish you well
i was an actor when i was uh they
thought i was gonna make money as an
actor as a kid i was a good looking
little kid so they're like now they
didn't have the wherewithal to pimp me
out yeah like they should have you know
what i mean they tried to play it
straight they did the play straight bad
movie
photos of my ass all over hollywood but
i was a bad actor trying to book a role
here
i had this voice at seven it was
horrible
anybody got a light yeah i was i was
like a cute kid and i'd walk in and i i
would audition for like big movies like
man in the house with jonathan taylor
thomas they'd be like all right so now
you're going out with your dad and he's
divorced and you know you you're
connecting with him again and but you
feel awkward and i'd get the script and
i'd be like okay i'd be like
mom is okay
i'm okay too and then they would be so
horrified so i didn't book anything for
years but that's what my parents thought
their get out of jail free
you were their beanie baby they were
they're the next baby baby i was the
next test truck
yeah
um what was the grocery store that you
went to growing up food town food town
yikes
out there no i don't think those are
meat farms there was either a wall bombs
but growing up it was food town
yeah jesus why you don't like you don't
want to get some briar's viennetta
remember the price
you would slide yeah that was that when
that thing hit they were marketing
exclusively to trash
exclusively
but somebody every once in a while
somebody would show up for dinner on a
weekday and that thing would come out of
the [ __ ] freezer and you would think
we were at [ __ ] le cirque in the
corner yeah sitting next to [ __ ]
madonna yeah you hear the crack when you
sliced it open very fancy the thing
about the bride's viennetta is basically
they like
they were marketing to people that go
you're not going to be able to afford to
go anywhere with a v vegas venice
this is the only v word you'll ever
volvo nothing nothing this is the only
word with a v you'll ever say in your
life dude they made the commercial there
was people smoking in the commercial
they made it look so clean you know what
i used to like i used to love a little
jello no bake
a jello no banana i don't even know what
that is no big pie a no big pot yeah a
jello no-bake pie where you would just
you would just kind of whip up a pudding
put cookies in it and then let it sit
yeah and it was nice you know about dirt
yeah my aunt used to make it every year
for for for like she still did we're all
30.
rule 30 and out of rehab
like a planner like fancy people would
put it they'd go to the store buy like a
planner yeah
it was disgusting and i would tell her
i'd go where somebody's people getting
out of rehab here for dope
uh it's not cute
it's not cute to eat dirt they're eating
literal dirt
they're eating literal dirt they they're
living in flop houses they're sucking
dick for smack sure i don't think that
that's not cutesy anymore it's not fun
to pretend that we don't have anything
yeah hang on hang back with the cookie
puss will ya trying to get my head on
straight with a couple cigarettes and a
stiff drink no [ __ ] why did we think
that was cool dirk because we're trash i
saw it at a birthday party it was my
[ __ ] mind when
any time you would see a cake i remember
a friend of mine had a cake with a wave
on it whoa yeah
yeah that wasn't any time you saw a cake
like that you're like
how do you feel popular living the
cookie cake the cookie cake like
remember back in the day they got big
they started i'm i like it
it's not enough
you know what i mean like i don't i
don't like anything
it's not the most honest answer i've
ever heard to me cookies are not the
thing they're a thing to enjoy it's like
an appetizer a plate of cookies you're
like you're on the dessert line
and you're trying to just
keep yourself good until you sit down
sure cookies are not like the cookie
cake i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
now you put ice cream in a minute like
you gotta you gotta jazz it up a little
bit yeah three layers and up at the
foley house yeah yeah
we were big on the watermelon roll from
friends
during mortgages when everything was
really hitting the ground quickly i
would stop at a friendly's do a jim
dandy at two o'clock in the afternoon
just a five scoop gym dandy
two o'clock in the afternoon alone
what's a gym dandy it's a five scoop
sunday from friendlies
with any type of ice cream you choose it
had fudge strawberry marshmallow whipped
cream sprinkles banana it was a [ __ ]
gym that was fantastic
dandy
friendlies was all right that was a big
fribble man great a good fribble they
made a good burger too
they made a good burger knew their way
around a steak fry they were all right
i'm not throwing a new england clam
cheddar out of my mouth and family
friendlies
a little clam strip in there i loved
friendlies kip let's talk about mint
mobile mint mobile let's talk about it
baby let's talk on the phone want to
know why you could talk on the phone
why's that because they're not banging
you over the head with contracts hidden
fees this that the other thing you're
not gonna believe it
15 a month that's how they're doing it
over that mint mobile 15
a month not too shabby one of your goals
for 2022 is to stop paying insane amount
of bills every month uh for wireless
switching to mobile is the easiest way
to save this year like the big man said
just 15 bucks
uh with mobile you choose the amount of
monthly data that is right for you and
stop paying data that you've stopped
paying for data that you never use
genius use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan to keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contracts or contacts there's no need
for you know switching over go reset the
thing plug it in pull it out bam like i
said my wife's been using it for years
she's a big fan it's easy peasy why sign
up for you know one of those big box
contracts where they you got your kids
in college or whatever
got you hold over the coals that's where
they get you so to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 beans a month uh and
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mint mobile.com garbage at
smithmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
mintmobile.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about movement baby man talk about
movement the romantic season is in the
air valentine's day is right around the
corner
movement knows that they're already
looking out for you if you got to pick
up your best guy your best gal or
whoever got to pick them up stuff for
valentine's day think about a nice watch
think about a nice ceramic uh bracelet
that they got over there yeah they got a
site-wide sail 18 carafine jewelry
pieces special edition styles stuff
you're not gonna find anywhere else but
movement look at that uh and you can
save on these gifts right now just
choose a watch and a matching accessory
and get immediate 20 off your order plus
free shipping and free returns as always
they got us we're we got the gear we
each got to watch we got the glasses my
lady uses the glasses watch sunglasses
the whole night i'm dripped out over
here they keep you yeah the drip is
fresh and it ain't nice and it don't
break the bank very affordable that's
their whole thing looking good for
affordable shop 20 off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmt.com garbage go to mvmvmt.com
garbage for your most stress-free
valentine's day gift giving
style shouldn't break the bank join the
movement do it yeah i loved carvel
carvel
which i still do it's the best guy's
voice that guy's always sold it yes yeah
the best software ice cream in a planet
great shakes you got gotta be an
entertainment's guy too i presume
entenmann's was great my favorite enter
there's a few entmans but
the one that i really like there's a few
of them that are really good there's a
chocolate chip cake
there's an entenmann's chocolate chip
cake
well first of all there's the
entenmann's devil's food with that
marshmallow
now let me tell you what you do with
that
you hold it you you freeze it you let it
get frozen you hold it upside down so
that the icing is like a plate
and then you eat the cake on top yeah
after it's been frozen you and it helps
to be high and it helps to be unemployed
a couple of newbies
i did that with tasty cakes i would
always eat them upside down because you
want the icing i want that to hit my
tongue you want to take like sushi good
sushi tell you fish first yeah same
thing i remember i found out i was
watching an ice cream documentary one
time ah not that long ago i mean what
are we doing what are we doing what
supposed to
we just got you a trainer and they
showed you the proper way to eat ice
cream they said don't use the spoon down
because the cold spoon hits your tongue
yeah and it desensitizes your taste buds
it's better to flip it over yeah i've
been flipping ever since people like me
and age foley like the trainer starts
very like we're gonna and then like like
a month in the trainer's like
the train was like
just when you're out to dinner
if you cause it starts with like we're
not eating now we're doing this we're
planning meals we're putting them in
tupperware
[Laughter]
it's soon it becomes just have one
dessert yeah like they they get fat
share an appetizer our trainers start to
get fat um but i literally just said
that yeah because we're leaving to go on
the road for a couple days he's like
after the show if you get a burger have
a burger don't get the fries maybe you
only have half a bun half a bun well we
come from the worst diet advice ever
which was like this like every diet that
was pitched in the 90s was like you can
have it all just be accountable yeah if
you eat that raw cookie dough just have
water later in the day
it all balances out snack wall cookies
were a big [ __ ] remember snackwells
they were like don't deprive yourself
yeah i'm like that's not what we need to
hear we've never deprived ourselves yeah
never
even thought about it yeah like my
mother like we talked about this on my
show
they all did this thing called deal a
meal where you get so
and then you'd go oh i get a cheat card
and then there would stop the insanity
this this lesbo susan powder
shaved head and she'd be like just eat
whatever just do this and so like my fat
mother and her friends would do this in
the living room
and then there was richard simmons
jenny craig nutra system [ __ ] the
slim fashion slippery fast curves
shake
the whole nine yards all of that slim
fast was [ __ ] all right i still like
a slim figure i used to i didn't know i
used to have them with meals i thought
they were chocolate milk i used to sit
there with a bag of peppers so good yeah
they're not bad no they're all right
that chocolate one's good what were the
snacks when you were a kid what would
your mom get what would you have what
was your lunches like free reign of it
so what i love i'm a big sandwich guy i
love like uh uh ham cheese turkey cheese
peanut butter and jelly
i love it i love a cold sandwich white
bread we're talking white bread
mayonnaise uh
cold sandwich like kept in the
refrigerator from the night before i
kind of liked that
um but i was a big school lunch guy fish
sticks tater tots sure canned string
beans
um pizza day on friday pizza day was
awesome it was amazing i love hot dog
day franks and beans were great then i
went to a high school there chicken parm
meatball what they got chicken parms at
your high school high school i go to an
olive garden
we had a great food i would go back to
that high school today
um i think it's illegal but i would
because they're they're meatball parm
they're chicken parm damn their uh bacon
cheeseburgers were
[ __ ] amazing barbecue chicken
sandwich really good but snacks growing
up me and my friend were little stoners
our favorite
food ever was barbecue chicken pizza and
it just debuted and the barbecue chicken
pizza we were at test market the primer
i remember when that came out the
barbecue pizza was at this restaurant
called jacks which later got shut down
for selling cocaine
they would sell they make the best food
though when you ordered a white we had
munchies when you ordered a white pie it
was blow
literally
we were selling cocaine but we would
also go we'd also i also want a white
box yeah
i'm gonna get two white pies
we're starving
um but the thing with the bbq chicken
pizza was just a regular pizza and they
would take breaded chicken cutlets chop
them up and throw them in this now i
don't know if you've ever had open pit
barbecue sauce now open pit i'm going to
teach you a lesson of trash
open pit
is and people can google it it is a
tangy metallic tasting
reddish brown it is the sauce that they
serve at most bars with steak tidbits or
with things like that
it's that kind of you eat it it's like
tang it's really catching here it gets
you in yeah it's a real most people just
don't love it i've gotten addicted to it
now if you heat it up it becomes like
yeah this chemical and
what they would do is just throw these
chicken cutlets they toss it with this
open pet which i've become addicted to
and just throw it on the regular pizza
and then hit it with another layer of
mozzarella so you get this regular slice
of pizza sausage cheese on top of that
just barbecued chicken and the chee and
you were just killing it so we would
love that that was a big
thing for us i just want to go on a
record real quick and say this is the
greatest episode ever right now
i am [ __ ] rock hard as we speak when
you said they hit it with another layer
of mozzarella my eyes rolled back in my
head we loved when we would get hugs we
get high
and we would love uh the original
grilled stuffed burrito at taco bell the
original which had the creamy pepper
jack sauce remember the original i've
tweeted at the my friend the original
menu at taco bell was [ __ ] top shelf
bring back the grilled cerrito and then
the original monterey ran chicken
sandwich at wendy's
he's lighting up when he's talking about
this bacon in the ranch
chopped up bacon in the ranch it was in
a gold wrapper [ __ ] you you know exactly
what i'm talking about
it was uh that's where they tried the
classic chicken patty monterey whatever
thing cheese monterey jack monterey jack
if it wasn't um and monterey jack cheese
lettuce tomato bacon and then ranch with
bacon in it it
yeah it was something else those were
the things i remember growing up
obviously i love mcdonald's fillet of
fishes i love the roy rogers fixing bar
i love the pizza i have enough love a
pizza hut lunch buffet oh
going to
four dollars that you could eat for the
week and then they had a dessert pizza a
little caramel apple dessert worse i
mean christ what was the going out to
dinner situation for the dillons as a
kid what would be well so my uncle is a
big restaurant guy so every now and then
we'd get to go to one that's where you
get it in the city yeah yeah
that's what's so interesting about you
you're from that but you have i have
some very good refinances
i have some high-end taste because my
uncle's a big restaurant guy so we used
to get to go
we used to get to go to restaurants and
eat really nice food every now and then
would it be known that it's we're going
out with uncles oh yes and would the
parents go or he would take you parents
would you ever parents of the family
sure but everybody knew he was paying
oh yeah everyone knew that they didn't
have to pass that's not ever got
everybody
but then
so big night out for us would be like
you know maybe my parents hated each
other so it was rare that they both go
out
but when they both go out it would be to
some local diner
or a place called itkins and valley
stream which was like an old you know
like an old like malt shop an old ice
cream parlor great ice cream socket to
me sunday 15 scoops
a lot of people
yeah oh you're sharing a [ __ ]
everything but but the kitchen sink
sunday yeah maybe 15 scoops um little
bacon ranch on there yeah it was wild
they would go to usually it would be a
diner
or maybe a little greek place
or a diner or a place called mcquaid's
like a birthday day graduation dinner
maybe an italian spot
okay any chains applebee's olive oil
fridays
so we grew up with fridays and outback a
little towards the outback came in later
fridays was a go-to the tostado nachos
where you split a taco shell down the
middle hit it with refried the cheese
um that's same friday's when they
brought out the jack daniels pulled pork
sandwich it changed my life
yeah i get it the jack daniels menu that
was your 911.
you're not kidding
every week
the jack daniels menu at fridays made me
know what was possible
you know there's life outside of long
island yeah in a way that i couldn't
understand i was like why yeah is this
so [ __ ] good
you want to hear an order this is my
order of fridays you want to get
i'd go in
there i said an adulterer as a kid as a
child jesus
this is what i used to do
listen honey get your pad and paper and
get over here
nachos
salad with because i love the fried
salad because they loaded it with cheese
croutons big shredded cheddar cheese you
get the breadsticks salad with ranch
tostado nachos salad with ranch
pulled pork sandwich it comes with
french fries
add on to that the loaded baked potato
now the load of baked potatoes what
little kids get a loaded baked pit
how's the divorce going buddy smart holy
[ __ ] a smart one because here's what i
would do i would get the extra jack
daniel sauce and it would go right into
the potato
and then like you have this loaded baked
potato with jack daniel sauce it's still
every now and then if i'm on the road
i'll go into friday's get a loaded mash
throw some jack daniel sauce on there
and eat it what are your parents saying
when you're when you're making this
order
they're kind of just
fine with it they're just like impressed
that i can order i'm like you know a lot
of kids are like
yeah yeah yeah tell them what you want
that's kind of funny you're speaking
about it a lot of kids are
like know so at least you're like you
can talk
yeah
i'm like are the toaster nachos
are they good today um who's cooking but
you know the answer to that is they were
horrible parents yeah
well i feel like the 90s like that was
wide open no the 90s nobody cared the
boomer and i'm working on a book right
now about boomers and the way they
parent it and
it's really like
amazing to watch the difference between
the way we were parented it's crazy it's
apparently it's nuts my parents might
have said a few times hey you should go
to college but they took no interest
like the idea of like them like going
around the schools with you for like the
weekend
won't you have fun here you'll like it
here like
they were such deeply selfish people
that had no designs on me becoming a
productive human being at all
they were incredibly selfish you know
um
you know morally questionable
demons from hell
we basically were just sharing sounds
like a nice little saturday
i mean you know guys were like roommates
we were we were just kind of like
hanging out yeah we're just hanging out
i get it no yeah for sure i remember
even like thinking i don't even think i
went on visit i went to i visited one
college i think by myself yeah i used to
smoke cigarettes in my grandmother's
house when i was like 13 14 just in the
house did she know they knew she knew
yeah i would smoke cigarettes in the
house they didn't care they didn't care
yeah that's [ __ ] my friend's mother
used to let us do coke weed everything
everybody's parents didn't do that they
hated drugs everybody's got that one
friend's house yeah you walk in you're
like i was i remember sitting in
something like i shouldn't [ __ ] be
here right this is bad right this is not
great you're always thinking like when
are your parents coming home yeah yeah
they're just never and then they're home
mother was a prostitute really she made
a lot of money in the 70s in the city
high-end call girl and bought a house
and everything great good looking
like she was then uh-huh she knew how to
she knew how to package that and she
said clean the pipes
her word's not mine
over a white pie yeah
all right let's get into some cues here
because we want to find out where you
stand on a lot of stuff yeah yeah you're
gonna set you you know we claim to be
experts at it but you
you can really set the tone or set those
you can lay the law yeah with certain
things before that though what was your
first stupid purchase when you got when
you when you got money what was the
range rover and i sold it months later
really because with the supply chain
you can sell it pretty easily i just
realized i'm like it was way too much
money for a car
um and how long ago was this is just
somewhat really a year ago really yeah
and i just realized i'm like
i don't
care that much
immediately you go i don't care like i
drive it for a while it's nice great
[ __ ] car but then i go
i don't need it i'd rather have the
money for other [ __ ] what is it now what
are you whipping around in right now i
just have rentals but i think i'm going
to get an electric
okay
like an electric caribbean
one of those new ones i i got on a list
for that a list
it's not that expensive it'll be a lease
that that you know you you uh you'll pay
the lease through your business of
course smoking the car
well i mean when you lease you can
i like how that's what you're worried
about yeah like that's gonna come
somebody at the ford dealership coming
after you well i don't know i mean we're
i'm trying to stop i stopped for months
and then i go back and then i start eat
in the car
you have to
i mean
those baked potatoes don't hold them
that's the best dancer ever
my favorite thing is going to the
drive-thru with the radios on listening
to something and have just [ __ ] drive
through food if you eat it in your home
you feel insane
i never got that i pull up in park right
away absolutely right away yeah you
bring it to your house and on like
unhappy
kitchen
have you ever seen mcdonald's on a plate
that means people are way too
comfortable
i'm like oh you've settled in for this
life of hell yeah that's real weird i've
seen it i've seen mcdonald's on a plate
the only one you could get away with a
little bit is kfc sure that's it yeah
yeah they sold that hard yeah that's
bringing it home to the defense because
it's in bigger portions too
i mean i man kfc honey barbecue wings
which they've discontinued
uh i mean kfc was a beautiful part about
when they started [ __ ] with dessert
when they were giving out whole cakes
well they used to have something called
a little bucket parfait they're
unbelievable there was strawberry and
there was chocolate and they were
unbelievable and the chocolate had it
was awesome what the [ __ ]
it was unbelievable it had a layer of um
uh like a graham cracker on the bottom
pudding and then a whipped cream and
then a foil on top of the
foil chocolate sprinkle had just kind of
like the die of the sprinkle it kind of
started to blend out let out a little
bit and blend out onto the whipped cream
that's the flavor i have offered
thousands of dollars to get one of them
and i
cannot like i would buy them like i've
offered
thousands of dollars for it so if you
guys are going to be i'm sitting
somewhere in the front or something kip
you like helix mattresses love helix
mattresses i'll say it one more time you
like helix mattresses no i love helix
man that's right and of course we all do
because you don't got to wander around
some mattress store like a bozo on a
saturday doofus you go over to the
website you take the quiz takes about
two three minutes you're in and out of
there they tell you exactly what kind of
mattress would be best for you could be
your sleep hot could be a sleep cold
could be you're on the bigger side you
need a little more cushion for the
pushing like old hair they got you
covered tippy's a client i know uh they
were nice enough to send us one of the
good folks at helix me and my wife like
i've said millions of times took the
two-minute sleep quiz we got the
twilight model loved it so much queen
size i put on a couple pounds we
upgraded to the king look at that now
we're swimming in a twilight helix
mattress loving life it's the first
adult mattress i've ever had guys i
can't stress it enough get involved with
helix if you're in the market for a
mattress helix is awesome but don't take
our word for it helix was awarded number
one best overall mattress pick by 20 for
2020 by gq and wired magazines that's
nothing to shake a stick out gq let's go
uh multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors sleep medicine offered as a
go-to solution for improving sleep so
just go to helix sleep.com garbage take
the two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you with a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life helix is offering up to 200.
200 beans up to 200 clams of all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time that's heelsleep.com
garbage now back to the show
now go to a restaurant i know it's very
food heavy yeah uh sparkling or still
still
really in a bottle or tap
it depends where i am new york always
tap really see thank you you're not
getting the bottle just for the short
top is better than everything wow but if
i'm in l.a where it's like cancer then
you get still a bottle of steel so it's
only at a necessity i figured you'd have
a bottle of pellegrino on the table just
for [ __ ] no i don't like i don't drink
anything with bubbles yes really i've
never drank soda i've never drank beer i
was an alcoholic i drank only hard
liquor wow yeah i'm stunned right i
don't like carbonation really it's odd
but i don't like it
um when you're out to dinner anywhere
will you take a bite and then sip your
drink do you bite and sip or do you
separate them
no i can't eat for a while and then i'll
drink then i eat for a while
here's a big one yeah go out to dinner
appetizers hit the table appetizers are
done you're sitting there you got
friends everyone's talking and hanging
out do you think it's okay to go out for
a cigarette and come back before dinner
gets there it is okay no it's not no i
don't know it's not dude
it's not and we agreed whatever he says
i don't usually do it i don't usually do
it it's trashy it's trashy yeah it's not
okay it's trashy it's not the right
thing to do but it's nice but you it's
allowed
too
i'm from the school of three or four
hour marathon dinners where people leave
and comment that's a little different
back they're on the phone they're
getting in fights outside they come back
in that's what i'm like you know people
have a lot of things going on yeah
you're waiting on somebody i have
friends that would go out and you know
do do a 20-minute phone call during
dinner and then come back in
you know like that type of that type of
comeback i mean i'll do it like
that
just come back you know that guy who's
constantly give me give me a minute and
then he's out there and he walks back in
like nothing happened yeah i had a buddy
just recently ago let me know when she
gets here i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
calling you outside to come back in so
you can place your [ __ ] order
uh all right uh i got one for you we've
never really talked about how do you
feel about hibachi restaurants hate him
hate him i hate him
the food's never good i don't like the
show okay and i don't like the people
that are into the show i'm there to eat
uh-huh i don't need a show i don't want
to see the smoke go through the onion
yeah
i'm not none of that's for me the shrimp
tastes like [ __ ] everything sucks i
don't like it you would never sit with
another
party i don't want that yeah okay all
right
what do you stand on split the check
where are you at i hate it hate it hate
it okay hate it so what do you do what's
the move
you get them the next time okay you get
them the next time
now for many years i was the guy that
got you the next time there was no next
was not gonna be enough until about
three weeks ago i was that guy my dad
tells a great story about a guy used to
always get everyone at the office to go
out for lunch let's go here for lunch
you want to go here for lunch and then
you get you know everybody would eat and
then the guy goes like he's got a little
light
and then everyone would pay for the guy
and the guy just kept getting away with
it i'm a little light in such a dirtbag
line
i'm a little lighter trying to save a
little bit i'm a little bit light i'm a
little got about eight bucks little one
what a great line
fantastic
anybody in the family addicted to
nicotine gum
oh interesting i think they all just
smoke okay
i mean we're doing it let's [ __ ] do
it yeah i mean i don't think not
stopping does most of your family smoke
uh they all used to some of them have
quit we don't i don't see them as much
anymore i don't know everyone lies sure
my family is liars all right so
they'll say they quit but no one's quit
okay
hmm will you tell the waiter at
someone's birthday at the table no i
hate it when it's someone's birthday
okay you don't sing
no i don't i don't even care about the
cuz you don't even get [ __ ] anymore
really for it it used to be like you'd
get something free now you don't even
get it yeah yeah it's like they just go
happy birthday and then you don't give
me something for free so [ __ ] you
people who ask is real trashy yeah as a
waiter i've had people come up so what
do you guys do for people's birthdays
right that's trash drop the check
somebody else yeah all right yeah
what do you do who's worthy we pay a
month to their rent
why is it your birthday
uh will you stay at a hotel on the first
floor no
will you swim in the uh in the hotel
pool will you go for a dip oh yeah okay
unafraid room service
all right that's what we were just
talking about room service is the reason
to stay in a hotel
really i've never really been in a hotel
that had some a good setup like i mean
here's the deal there's only a few
hotels in america that do it where
they're coming with a literal table with
china wow
and a white cloth you know and they i i
mean the beverly hills hotel the mark in
new york city there's a few hotels where
they'll bring a porterhouse to the room
whoa that's crazy porterhouse some
french fries maybe a quesadilla 2 a.m
beverly hills hotel when i'm staying
there in l.a but now i have my apartment
i don't have to stay there but
i used to just tell my friends meet me
at my room and i would just order a
shitload of rooms there's something
about room service it just feels good
cozy it's good to eat in the room i feel
like you're gaming the system a little
bit that's right yeah are we still
flying coach at all never really first
class all the time are you paying or
never never again i'll never fly
coaching i'd rather literally die
i i would rather get on a plane that's
crashing
where i knew it was gonna crash then sit
and coach again
i would never
literally i would get on a plane where
they go this has one engine the other
one
but we're you're in first okay okay all
right i'm a big dude you can't you could
coaches are not fun i like it i like it
i like it
any lottery winners in the family
anything like that sadly no
my mother used to go like this she used
to tell people she used to go you got to
buy scratch offs in bad areas because
there's more winners because the
government wants to help those people oh
my god
holy [ __ ]
wow that's a little fun fact right there
holy moly misses that was mama
that's next level dirtbag right there
uh will you put potato chips on a
sandwich
you know i never loved it but i'm not
against it but i never loved it okay
okay i never loved it but i don't hate
it do you own an air fryer
someone bought me one i've never used
okay how do you feel about that person
supposing air fryer has changed your
life yeah because every fat person is on
and off keto
every fat person is talking to the
baddest people you know are on the keto
diet the fattest people you know if you
know and they all they go it's just you
hit it with the air fryer
just hit a pork chop with an air fryer
i'm not doing it i don't care much about
it
[ __ ] that uh uh will you take food on a
plane
like when you buy it in the terminal not
really okay not really anymore you're
eating the airplane food though right
yeah i'll eat the food on the plane okay
you know it's respectable i like it you
take your shoes off when you fly no okay
take your shoes off in anybody's house
yeah you do some people's house yes what
about you do you at your house is his
shoes off i don't require it but some
people do okay it really depends it's
like i'm not i'm not like a nazi about
it there's not a basket up front by the
door no no no no no i don't i don't kind
of care either way
okay what are your thoughts on
cauliflower rice
i've tried that
i mean i'm not gonna lie i don't even
mention it by name
i've had a pokemon i ran into it at a
party i've had a pokeball in l.a with
cauliflower rice and it's like this
ready
[Music]
something's missing it's like i'm
surviving yeah yeah that that's what you
feel like when you eat it you go i am
surviving
i will survive do you [ __ ] with any of
the foam dishes that are popular now
will you go to a place that has the foam
dishes
oh like a really high-end molecular
gastronomy whoa what the [ __ ] was that
that's what the foam is yeah holy
molecular gastronomy meaning that they
they they change the uh you know the
states of food yeah make things into
jellies and foams and whatever
yeah [ __ ] with it it's never been my
favorite but i'll i'll have a little fun
you're more of an up to middle american
steakhouse
i like a corporate steakhouse i like a
menu that i know by heart like i know my
best friend's secrets like i want
everything to be the same
all the time if that [ __ ]
salad dressing is different i like a
menu where it's the menu is planned in a
board room
[Laughter]
truly there's a flow chart about this
yeah
i used to go to all the high-end
restaurants and molecular gastronomy
should like that right i used to do all
of that but now you've settled back and
i could still enjoy some of that but if
you ask me the restaurants that i grew
up in that i really love
is steakhouses okay who does it shrimp
cocktail lime ace potato
ribeye black and blue little porterhouse
iceberg iceberg with a little blue
cheese wedge shrimp scampi or baked
clams
a little oysters rockefeller yeah i mean
that's where i that's where i'm living
do you think appetizers should be
ordered individually or should they be
ordered for the table for the table and
share it they should never be ordered
individually do you think it's trashy if
multiple people at the same table order
the same dish i would go this far okay i
almost think at a steakhouse there
should be a little meeting up front
and then one person should order for the
whole table
we just did that yeah just have a
meeting just right just have a meeting
have a little meeting what do you like
you're medium rare your this your that
your rare your medium we'll compromise
it medium rare what do we do this is a
family style thing
let's one guy come here here are the
apps we want do the entries we want it
is not an individual thing
i think you order steak for the table
sides for the table yes that to me is
the steakhouse
that's what i believe
that's what i believe
yeah you know
what i was taught if you go out to
dinner if you're bringing your friends
out to dinner it's tim's dinner yeah are
you you're leading that charge you're
handling i'm usually leading the charge
because my friend get letting my friends
order would be like giving them ape the
constitution
and telling them the fashion effect of
government like
my friends are idiots and they'll
mispronounce words and they don't know
anything and
they're frugal and [ __ ] yeah i like it
when you do when you do a steakhouse you
got to start with a shellfish tower if
you can
cold seafood tower cold seafood tower
chickens
first thing to hit the table is a cold
seafood tower first thing boom boom
oyster shrimp lobster crab little clams
whatever
that's out cold appetizers are done
then you bring in the hot appetizers if
you're gonna do any of them maybe it's a
warm goat cheese salad maybe it's a
lobster bisque it's not my business
maybe it's a baked clams maybe it's a
shrimp scampi whatever it is maybe it's
a gorgonzola bread a garlic bread with
gorgonzola cheese sauce yeah a little
bit but there's got to be a little hot
appetizer yes actually just a little a
little nibble then there's a salad for
the table then you hit the
porterhouse for two three four whatever
yo gratin the lining whatever you want
to do cream spinach cream spinach
broccoli garlic and oil
asparagus whatever how's that steak
cooked
i like rare but on certain cuts i'll go
medium rare wow you're a rare i'm a rare
guy yes sometimes i'll do a medium teach
that no sometimes i'll do a medium rare
if it's a rib eye the fattier a steak
the longer it should be cooked so if you
do a rib eye steak really should be
medium rare
filet or anything like that is rare to
black and blue sushi grade
um damn but wow a bone in new york strip
usually rare plus that's the term you go
rear plus yeah meaning
rare but a little more than what you're
doing a bone-in strap anything with a
bone you're gonna do rare plus rib eyes
medium rare
anything
strip steaks
fillets rare
to black and blue pittsburgh style which
is sushi [ __ ] laying it down
everyone's [ __ ] taking notes out
there take notes jesus who
in new york does that well
for you
just ask him flat out what's your
favorite statement in new york quality
meets is a one that i really like but i
mean i i love lugers and old homestead
and smith and wolinski's and strip house
and quality meats and quality italian i
i love you know maria which is a pasta
restaurant did a great 50-day age creek
stone but they're not they're no longer
doing that cut anymore which upsets me
um every here's the thing about new york
every single restaurant french italian
everything they have a great new york
steak on the menu if it's a good
restaurant yeah every restaurant in new
york city has a usually a great new york
strip on the menu he didn't say ours i
know you believe yours keens no we
haven't been to keane yet we're
gallagher's men
i've been to gallagher's i don't dislike
gallagher
i don't dislike gallagher [ __ ] what do
we got to be going we've been to quality
meats yeah i don't dislike algae's i
think again
for me
steak is very similar it's never about
the steak that's what that's what we
were talking like hey they all do a
really good steak
don't give a few points this way or that
what i like about quality meats is
they're they have homemade ice creams
their desserts are sick their shellfish
tower is insane
their sides they do a gnocchi and cheese
instead of a mac and cheese which is
great yeah quality meats was fantastic
yeah
[Applause]
we're still doing medium well over here
i don't know no you're learning
what was the pet situation growing up
was there any
two cats one named sam one named mariner
because the cat supposedly jumped off a
boat and swam to shore
jesus
you know
sam died and was like like frozen in a
position and my mother left it in the
room for three days
whoa no dogs because my mother said she
was allergic but we found out that was a
lie
that's awesome yeah
rules with an iron fist over there what
are your thoughts on fish tanks
so it's there's a certain type of house
that can really do it
certain there's a certain part of the
country
if i if i walk into an arizona desert
mansion i want to see some tropical fish
you know what i mean if you've done well
outside of scottsdale i want you to show
me with brightly colored fish yeah show
me a shark or something yeah there's
certain types of the country certain
parts of the country new york it should
be not allowed
unless you're in long island if you're
in long island it's you might be able to
get away with it florida i'm big into it
okay i'm big into a big fish tank in
florida palm springs california out in
the desert
uh
uh arizona these are where fish tanks
are allowed
are allowed yeah
oh
god
how do you feel about leftovers
i hate them i hate um
i hate to go i hate to go
it's a poverty mentality my parents had
it my mother would scrape mashed
potatoes into a coffee cup at a diner
and walk out with it and a coffee cup
yeah that's what they give you it's a
and they give you the you know the
little oh like i was like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think it's a poverty
mentality of like
that there will you'll you'll there'll
be more mac and cheese
i i don't love it i know some people
like i've gotten arguments
about this with people this is a big
topic on the show i overeat
i've never eaten more than you should
eat yes nothing's as good the next day
really
yeah no that's why you have fast food i
know foley you're making face but that's
why you have fast food
fast food get this guy out of here
throw this bomb at the door delis and
diners and fast food is for the next day
yes when you want something good but you
realize hey we're not going to go back
to [ __ ] the steakhouse you go and get
a nice deli sandwich yes i'm a big it's
got to be you know
it's got to be like the way it should be
yeah i don't i don't have a problem i
want to make out you want to do take out
that
ball at home yes that's different
you wake up the next day it's like it's
kind of yeah you got a half a chicken
breast and you're like throwing it on a
pan
what about pizza cold pizza the next day
that's different that's not taking pizza
home though you get pizza delivered get
pizza take pizza home
now you do uh if you do order in right
yeah you you get it delivered or
whatever uh taking this is also tough to
reheat
it either gets put in the oven it takes
too long too long this guy's crazy wait
in 45 minutes for a slice of [ __ ]
pizza kick rocks you put it in the
microwave it comes out it's very foldy
and hot but it's not you know it's not
cheese doesn't get that you don't like
it yeah yeah did you have a frozen pizza
as a kid that you preferred
we didn't mind dealios
red baron red berries all right yeah
gentlemen okay but when you get when you
do get takeout well you played it
it depends what it is okay uh a lot of
times no just out of the container yeah
l.a uh so many people we do postmates
okay i am so hungry
by the way i i had nothing i just go to
galagas will change your mind i had one
cigarette then i ran out of matches oh
my god dude
matches too much money i don't know
where my lighter was so i just had
matches i found him in a car ever five
matches ago dude lifesaver [ __ ] and they
it was two matches i'm like first one
burned out
second match and i got it and then i was
driving down here and now we've just
talked about food for an hour and i'm
like [ __ ] i know i would love to
get a [ __ ] statement i know you guys
got to go to [ __ ] hartford unless i
take you somewhere one day we'll i'm
here for a while i'm gonna get you
something yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll do
we'll do it nice we're paying by the way
but no no here's the deal here's what
i'm gonna do
i'm gonna drive you to long island
oh
hey don't don't tease me timmy i'll take
your money
italian restaurant it'll change your
life is there is there a particular
giant's jersey you want us to wear a few
rules there's a few rules donald trump
is still the president
that's number one my parents are coming
anybody here do you want the chicken
cochitoria or not
[Laughter]
swear is your presidency
let's step into the bathroom for a
second yeah do you pee in the shower oh
yeah who doesn't yeah okay i mean that
would be insane a lot of weirdos crazy
to not what about brushing your teeth in
the shower i haven't done that i don't
really do that yeah it's not a judgment
thing that's trashy though i just don't
do it it's trashy what are we using do
we got a bar we have uh body wash body
wash any specific brand or just
whatever's on the shelf it's usually
like uh i have like a dove sensitive
skin [ __ ] thing okay okay all right
it's not bad do you mess with any
high-end self-care products keels or
anything like that using anything like
that
and then i'll do like a penoxyl acne
wash okay okay yeah growing up it wasn't
dove body wash i would assume right no
i'm trying to think what do you do
grandmother used to have dial and
that'll take her skin off i love the
smell of that they use that on the space
shuttle dude remember dial oh my god
style that yellow bar dude dial would
take your skin off she was like a spider
she molted
she got out of the shower like an old
lobster she would get me dove because
she knew i had sensitive skin that's
good irish skin yeah so do i so dry
style
i would use dove
um in terms of a
shampoo
[ __ ] my mother was like pantene okay
pantene
i had a huge marketing campaign in the
90s my grandmother what the hell because
i could picture a strawberry suave in
your bathroom i don't know my gr now i
just use like a dandruff shampoo like a
tea gel or something like that nizoral
um
but i'm trying to think what my
grandmother used
my mother every now and then would [ __ ]
with the vidal sassoon
horrible essence or something every now
and then she'd [ __ ] a couple baby babies
that week yeah she'd [ __ ] with a
uh something like that okay who would
babysit you as a kid mostly your
grandmother my grandmother and then like
you know my my mother had this girl that
she actually moved into her house for a
few years named dorothy who's one of her
like favorite swimmers from the swim
team and dorothy came from an abusive
family
my mother moved her in and she kind of
babysitted me wait hold on she moved
this girl into your house into my house
as you were growing up as i was growing
up i was like uh young eight something
like that how old was the girl
oh teens 14 15 16. they moved her in
yeah she was from like an important bad
situation yeah yeah
relationship
[Laughter]
have standalone hot tubs at any point
ooh
great question
you know got they got like
3 500 together a couple married no kids
it's on the back of a condo or something
i'm trying to remember if anyone had a
standalone sitting on a loose deck
probably never worked yeah
[ __ ]
i'm trying to remember i did not
immediately
i remember standing on top any family
members with birthdays that fall on a
holiday any christmas babies any new
year's babies
no okay
anyone in your family ever owned a pt
cruiser
no not that i remember what about a
hummer any hummers in the family no
really no harm i'm stunned by that my
aunt worked for mercedes so she got
people deals really on thanks every now
and then her family the majority then
they fired her mm-hmm
i don't know if i want to get like an
s600 or this so i called her and she
drives a kia by the way she goes listen
she goes i just because i was fired by
mercedes and she goes i'm here at jaguar
and she goes i'm probably they're
probably gonna let me go here too
[Laughter]
but she goes but don't get one of these
these are not good i'm like okay thank
you
she's just being fired by every car
every luxury car dealership on long
island um this is a big one on the show
uh you're going to a wedding
right
not i'm i'm really never invited i'm
invited to so few weddings really so few
weddings
i was a guy that was just like
i wouldn't go to a lot of weddings
and i had comedy so i like just you know
my best friend i remember i was supposed
to go to his wedding
i
they had to drop out of mohigan son i
told him i said dude this is one of my
first headlining i'm like gotta do it i
have to get in this rotation he totally
understood but i've been with you so i
could probably answer i feel like now
they gotta be this you're gonna gotta be
coming in woodwork this may your mailbox
gonna be full a lot of my friends are
not getting married and a lot of them
have gotten married and it's already
failed okay uh let's just say it's a
friend from high school a cousin not not
like you know ben or yeah like somebody
kind of close but whatever yeah what's
in that envelope what are you given
oh
interesting
maybe a grand whoa
i didn't want to know what you gave the
kid what you gave him
got a lot of money
yeah yeah i would never get any ideas
for it
i would never say what he got of course
yeah we would have asked you know fifty
thousand i gave him fifty thousand
dollars literally i gave him seriously i
gave him fifty grand are you paying tax
free seriously we we structured each
other's tax free fifteen grand what like
fifteen over the next three no fifty
grand just i like we structured it so as
a bonus without taxes for my business
manager dinner
holy [ __ ] wow
50 cheese yeah [ __ ] dylan i am
baldwin i love him and he's great of
course he's my family but you know does
that look like he said i wouldn't ever
say the number
it was 100 i wouldn't say the number
does that get around the wedding do you
notice that maybe a half hour 45 minutes
i'm sick of giving people [ __ ] and not
talking about it
do you know what i mean yeah i know
you're [ __ ] sick of it so maybe
you'll get around
[Laughter]
are you garbage what are you gonna do i
got a 1500 everybody's a question are
you garbage do you give your best friend
a present and then talk about it on a
popular podcast in hopes that other
people hear it also that's a good
question you structured it as a bonus i
love it let me talk to my guy yeah it's
a bonus yeah um god damn damn a jihad's
good a thousand's good yeah is that a
hug is that a hug when he finds out yeah
he's autistic but it's not so hot
holy [ __ ]
man
plus keeping the tax man out of it i
even like that too yeah why let them win
fairness
they got me a book about spiders
i'm kidding i love it's fun no of course
this is what the show is
also too uh what is obvi you don't have
to i mean
if you don't have to say the person or
whatever what is the most amount of
money someone has asked you to borrow
really i've never gotten that really
yeah as of late you're not paying
anybody's legal fees or medical bills or
anything right now no i know what's
hitting you he does walk around with you
know the answer is probably going to be
no yeah i was going to ask you my
friends
my friends are drug addicts sure so they
all it's i know it's for drugs
it's not like my friend's like i got a
good business idea yeah
it's drugs it's drugs
it's all drugs
trying to get a couple of white pies
over here
trying to get a couple investors in this
eight ball what do you think oh drugs
yeah okay all right so it's not even
like i'm a dick because i would help
people if they like it's like i they
will die
sure huh how about cruises what do you
feel about them
hate them
i hate them hate them but only because i
i took the impractical joker's cruise
and i performed on it and uh
yeah i just
the thing with me and cruz i don't like
i like being near the land
sure if i'm on the boat i like to see
the land of course i don't like to be
out in the middle of a
uh
with with like who where's the doctor
[Laughter]
i get nervous how many lawyers are on
this boat that's what i want to know i
get nervous there's 1580 year olds
eating fondue where's the doctor
uh preferred benedict would it be
traditional
salmon crab cake or florentine
and is there a right answer
and how do you feel about the eggs
benedict as a whole
lobster black truffle wow
what
you think he was gonna say [ __ ] crab
cake we got tim [ __ ] dylan lobster
black truffle benedict at the peninsula
what's to say where does a gentleman
like that get something like that yeah i
like lobster black trough but i love a
smoke my actual favorite one not trying
to i'm just you know is the smoked
salmon benedict is my favorite okay lox
benedict is my favorite
but here's what's really good
um
truly
like i've had a lot of different kind of
benedicts
[Laughter]
cumberbatch all of them
name another podcast for somebody who
says that yeah
they've won
i've had a lot of benefits i've had a
short rib benedict oh yeah that's great
i mean i've had like obviously the crab
cake benedict the lobster black truffle
i've had a smoked salmon benedict i've
had the california eggs better dick so
the california eggs benedict you add
avocado and tomato and replace a
canadian bacon with real bacon america
i'm in i like it i had one in philly not
too when we did a show in philly and
went to i think it's called like green
eggs or something pretty good restaurant
and they did a cheesesteak one philly
cheesesteak one
pulled my [ __ ]
only second to the grenade sauce
obviously for sure yeah that's uh
something else do you think it's
acceptable
at a breakfast instead of getting home
fries french fries are okay what do you
think yeah my mother did that all the
time french fries lightly cooked
lightly cooked she loved lightly cooked
french fries i don't know what what was
wrong what are you are you a i don't
care french fries to me i'm whatever
they're there i eat them i don't care
sure not you can't be too picky even if
they're bad i'm
like a mashed potato yeah like to me
home
and
feeling good
is garlic mash or a little loaded mash
or a gorgonzola mash
or to me it's i need you know that
warmth of the french fry to me is my kfc
ain't too shabby with the mashed
potatoes it's a nice smash but it's not
bad how do you feel about chatomet uh
mashed potatoes at del frisco's are
amazing
is that with the cheese in it and little
chopped peppers oh
boy
take me home country roast
how do you feel about the twice baked
potato
like it it's very catering hall yeah
sure it's a catering hall staple and i
don't mind it you do a few off the top
and then throw it yeah you get another
one you just gotta do the top yeah yeah
yeah okay it's a catering hole it's a
chicken frances pennella vodka eggplant
rollatini twice baked potato little
steak tip chicken marsala or something
yeah a couple of free drinks you bang a
couple of more bee lights on the patio
and you get out of there dude i just did
that exactly at a funeral
you get in and get out yeah
huh i got i mean i only got one or two
left i think okay
i got another three hours yeah i know
we haven't even gotten into dessert yet
i don't know where the [ __ ] anybody
thinks they're [ __ ] i never i don't
know when i'm gonna get this kid back
here this is our
but
like we're like 2-0 something amazing
i've never
i mean i've never
you've met your match in how you two
talk about food it's like it's an
attitude you blink like sharks it's eyes
roll back it's like pacino and de niro
and heat
that's what's happening right now it's
coming from the mentality of an addict
yeah you know it's i i you know you get
into it 100 percent you're an addict
talking about drugs they really go into
it they don't it's not just it's not
just heroin yeah
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
cobblers how do you feel
i feel like a cobbler right i enjoy a
cobbler my problem
with a cobbler
and this has been something that has
never been said anywhere listen we've
got a nice time so far don't [ __ ]
ruin it now but my problem with the
cobbler is there's such a variance you
either know what you're doing when you
make one or you know my aunt will bring
a cobbler and you go what did you sue
yeah
sue just crumbled cookies what'd you do
here yeah you're watching oann screaming
about queuing on you're not paying
attention
[Laughter]
to peaches yeah you put a couple of
oatmeal cookies in a blender and threw
them on top of some cherries cause
you're screaming about hillary clinton
eating babies follow the recipe
take the top box
god damn that was what i had have you
ever done the recipe on the box of
anything
um are you a cook are you cooking much i
can cook pretty good if i want i can
really cook cooking at the house i make
one thing i make three things i make a
chocolate souffle
whoa kill a chocolate that's crazy how
would you learn to do that it's the one
thing i learned when i was a young kid
who taught you that
i don't know just i'd watch a lot of the
food shows yeah and it's just whipping
egg whites you fold in the chocolate you
put it in a water bath and have you ever
had a chocolate it's the greatest thing
you'll ever have i had a vanilla souffle
not that long ago in paris it's it's
well excuse me
that's patreon.com so i'll show you
garbage folks
i've been waiting to save paris for the
last hour
when when when me and you say the word
paris it just sounds like it should be
followed up with somebody going
license and registration
the question was license
and registration alien parish
sir do you own this car what was the
question i just planned to get we were
talking about souffle oh yeah so i make
a souffle
i make really good scrambled eggs
because it's just gone
slow slow with american cheese low and
slowly
american cheese yeah i love the american
cheese there's an egg cheese
cheddar is not to be on and by the way
what's in the egg cheese america cheese
is for eggs for burgers it's so much
it's better on burgers yeah cheddar is
for potatoes
cheddar is for mexican food it's for
potatoes or it's for eating raw sharp
cheddar with cheddar yeah but american
cheese people say oh it's not a cheese
nothing's anything shut up
you know what i mean make that reddit
burger cheese you just said are you a
smash burger or thick patty guy well if
i'm in new york i do a new york
steakhouse burger where of course i have
a thick slice of honey
of course and uh you know i i do like a
big thick burger with ground sirloin
it's nice but nice tomato a little white
onion ketchup some cheese but if i'm in
la i'm smashing it up we're doing the
patties we're doing the cali style well
in rome yeah when in rome what is the
most money you've spent on a hamburger
what's the most expensive burger you've
had maybe 25 or something it's not bad
it's not that bad that place in chicago
that's all that is is 25 bucks is that
what well yeah yeah it's not that
expensive that's not bad you do minetta
yeah it's overrated oh
that first minetta then gallagher's this
guy's
yeah you're [ __ ]
you're shattering mirrors i like minetta
the black label is good
but it's not what it was sure i'll take
you to the bar in freeport long island
called the helm that's got a better
burger than all this yeah we gotta just
clear one day and we'll do three meals
the best food in the country no no i'll
take you to a strip mall italian that's
better than three star restaurants in
new york we just said that like yeah
yeah like the duck's really good out
there i mean you know long island's got
some food they don't blow you away if
you know where to go
how do you feel about turtlenecks
not for me not for bigger guys
um how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from like a supermarket oh i
love that yeah well it's healthy
if you want to be healthy your family
ever buy [ __ ] off tv any wrong
commemorative place my mother was insane
with qvc for years
i'd walk in she'd be like scribbling
into a pad at 1am i'd be like because by
the way after easy payments after
midnight qvc they start marketing to
they know who's watching yeah they know
they're crazy they know who's out so my
mother would be like [ __ ] i'd be like
what's going on because it's jaclyn
kennedy's engagement
i'm like all right i'm sure it's not but
99.99 yeah i'm like i'm gonna go out for
butts still got blood on it
holy [ __ ] i mean
i hope this was a fun this is
are you kidding me
i hope this was worth it of course of
course we've been waiting a long time
this is fantastic am i garbage we don't
know
so hard
it's such a it's so close you all i mean
it's such a photo finish
but in the first three minutes you
called percocet perkadoos
all right nice perk-a-doodle-doo yeah
here's the thing
i i'm garbage but i've maybe ascended a
little you've well you know
no not even ascended a little you have
it inherent inside of you you have
high taste you you you you have a yeah
you can walk in both worlds that's right
day walker man yeah you're crazy in such
a way that that blows me away wow like i
would be full confident to walk into the
most you know classy expensive situation
with you leading the way yeah you know
how to handle yourself at a cocktail
party out in the [ __ ] hamptons yeah
you know how to [ __ ] talk to people
and stuff like that yeah yeah i know i
can i can do it but then you also like a
strawberry quick every once in a while
every there's nothing better than a
bacon egg and cheese and a nestle quick
that's the trashiest thing i think has
ever been said that that was my last
question what is your go-to chocolate
milk
that's a quick i love was that what you
had as a kid yes was it the powder you
got no it was the little queen i got the
bottles um that's pretty classy i like
it because to me
i remember
believing that that bunny
cared
about the product
you know what i mean now you look at the
mascots you know they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah they'll just eat it for the money
they're in it for the money now that
honey nut cheerio bee was really going
for it uh but to me i love but so
here's also the reality
i also like hershey's of course i love
what's your favorite chocolate that's
the correct just chocolate no snickers
like a chocolate bar
hershey's just a hershey's straight up
favorite fruity candy
skittles starburst
brunch
dots no i'm gonna go with dots get out
of here i'm gonna go what's the chewy
one
squishy chewies hai chew no starburst
mike and ikes uh
like little what do they say square
give me something here they're like
shaped like gushers maybe okay
interesting i don't know i don't know i
can't believe you couldn't pull that i
was like you were
i'm not a huge candy guy really not a
huge kid what's your problem with lava
cake too you don't like lava cake
this has been bothering him for 18 hours
bother me for a long i got bone to pick
with you buddy is the lava cake good or
are they just chewing you on the cake
and there's the first cut
well we got the clip thank you just
barry barry white says i can
um i i if don't fill a cake with
something unless don't fill a cake with
something that runs away yeah that's not
as good as the cake yeah what do we do
just make a hot chocolate cake give me
some ice cream cut it out yes there's
nobody that's had a great hot chocolate
cake in one but why doesn't it melt away
why is it sixty percent of this gone
yeah why doesn't want the dominoes are
pretty good last night you want let me
let me let me show you
let me show you what we did last night
because we were being inappropriate
and i want to show you what we did last
night because you have to hold on ready
you have to see this whoa holy [ __ ]
we're a quality italian okay and we're
doing the s'mores we're doing a tiramisu
cake blood orange gelato that's a
chocolate olive oil cake
that's how you do it you just saw you
ordered everything for the tape
everything for the table for the tape
espresso afterwards yeah and then i
don't drink it but in the window i used
to but i don't and when the women go to
eat you very you judge them harshly you
go
when they go to eat you go
and that way just the men will split it
and then the woman get like a fork full
and then go yeah hey did you say
something like that like you want more i
think it had some already
ladies and gentlemen
mr tim dillon home run home [ __ ] run
100 garbage thank you so much the most
eclectic garbage that could possibly be
good garbage one man's trash is another
man's ass trucks
uh what do you got cooking with anything
you want comedy.com we've got a tour
that we're winding up we're shooting a
special march in denver we're announcing
that tomorrow awesome we've got some
cool venues of ryman theater coming up
in uh nashville and a bunch of other
stuff and this is the end of the tour
and then i hop off torn march and i
chill for four months love it stay on
the internet
any plans any big vacations anything
like that no what is timmy like to to
relax a little bit
i don't know i like going to florida a
lot i love florida that's trash well
that puts you over the top right there
yeah i love florida i just love it i
don't need i get it it's dropping a lot
where do you go i go like a lot of west
coast
saint pete beach clearwater
i was talking about about it we did the
dances are yeah i love the dances and
they're all time collected all the time
he was making fun of me i was like damn
dylan no i love the dances nice it's a
great thing it's expensive but nice it's
great they didn't have a staff for about
eight months
they were a little
everybody's coming back to work
everybody's discovered their passion for
customer service
ladies and gentlemen mr tim dylan pippi
what do you got for him just check out
patreon we're on the road we're all over
the [ __ ] country go get some [ __ ]
tickets i can write comedy on all social
media do it gang we love you we'll see
you next week peace